next up harry styles is making headlines
for some baby news but guys it's not his
baby not his baby i know when i saw this
i was like oh my god
i don't know i know i'm sort of like
other people wishing it was their baby
etc but it's not his baby but people
reports that he paused a concert in
nashville recently in order to do a
gender reveal on stage four fan okay so
before opening the envelope he got on
the phone with the daddy of the baby and
he asked the crowd to count him down so
take a look at this
can we get a countdown
[Applause]
a little baby girl
that is really sweet that's actually
heard a lot about this but i hadn't seen
it in a clip yet yeah yeah i had i feel
like a lot's going on he's been giving
dating advice on tour
there was a fan apparently in the
audience and he was given dating advice
if he's like not good to you any games
being played cut him out cut him loose
he should come on this show that's all
we do is talk about dating and fighting
right come here
i hadn't seen that video either but it's
so sweet i mean well you know
everybody's always trying to top
everybody else on the gender reveal
parties they use fireworks okay guess
what you lost to harry styles this is
how you do it this is the best gender
reveal of all time it's over yeah um
harry styles pulled double duty on snl
uh how was his week oh my gosh
remarkable he was so good he was
basically like a cast member it was like
someone stepping in and i don't know
what we expected of him but he stepped
in and was like he's part of the family
he knows what he's doing he makes big
choices he's so kind he really is kind
guys like irl kind kind kind kind of in
real life in real life in real life i
was translating for people for the
people at home don't know irl
i just figured out what i
but he really is so sweet in real life
and honestly having him reveal the
gender of your baby is incredibly
special because what a tender man in a
tender moment yeah everybody really
loves him and i think sometimes when
everybody loves someone i'm like oh i'm
good but with him i'm like yeah i gotta
yeah yeah he's so great he's he's
absolutely wonderful i was sort of like
that's a confident baby daddy though
who's like harry styles is calling me
talking about my baby
it's a little dicey he's looking at his
wife like
okay remember me
[Music]